hey guys
do you want to get a tattoo
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well don't not yet not until you've
watched this video because in this video
i'm gonna show you seven big tattoo
mistakes most men make
it's gonna be an interesting video so
let's get to it
[Music]
all right guys now just so you know
around 25 of americans got tattoos and
here's a shock
50 of them want to remove their tattoos
according to the adultman.com now as you
can see there are a lot of guys out
there who don't like their tattoos
so let's get to this list after two
mistakes you don't want to make
your girlfriend's name
don't do it
you might feel that you're in love and
you think you'll never lose her but you
don't know the future if you break up
believe me you don't want to be stuck
with her name tattooed on your body
permanently
never make a hasty decision don't get
that tattoo just because you're in a
rush because if you do you're probably
going to regret it especially if you're
young why because you will change over
the years and then 10 years from now
that spongebob tattoo
well you're not going to like it anymore
i got a tattoo and i waited until i was
in my mid 30s before i got one i thought
about it for years until finally i knew
i was ready i knew what i wanted
[Music]
don't get it just because you think it
looks cool that's just silly why do
people get tattoos just because they
think they'll look cool or especially
they think other people will like them
more if they have a tattoo
that's just silly getting a tattoo is a
personal thing and you need to get a
tattoo that has a special meaning for
you one that will
continue to have a special meaning until
you're 60 70 80 years old for example my
tattoo always reminds me of my faith
how lost arrogant and bad i really was
before i found true faith in god and
became a better person
another big mistake is choosing the
wrong tattoo artist
they're all different some are terrible
some are okay and some are great if you
want a great tattoo that looks good and
will last long you have to go to the
right tattoo artist you need to do your
homework your research because that's
what they are artists and not one artist
is the same
[Music]
choosing the wrong spot
where do you want your tattoo do you
want it on your face well it's probably
not a good idea especially if you still
want to work in corporate or do other
types of jobs many companies will just
close their doors to you because you
have a tattoo that's visible for example
healthcare professionals law enforcement
banks receptionists law firms teachers
hotels resorts cruise ships government
airlines and many others and then some
countries won't like it like japan if
you go to japan which is an awesome
country i love it i've been there a few
times but if you go there you need to
cover up your tattoo open tattoos there
well that's a big no-no especially
because of the yakuza and then if you're
a guy if you want to get a tattoo on
your lower back that's probably not a
good idea that's more feminine and on
your v-line
no that's just no
[Music]
getting a common tattoo why would you
want it to too
that so many other people already have
you know these common tattoos like the
barbed wire the basic tribal tattoo and
those chinese names you hope it says
what you wanted to say
instead just get something unique don't
follow trends
misspelled tattoos
you might laugh as well but when it
happens to you because it does happen
then you won't be laughing anymore
make sure you double check this spelling
and double check the artist before you
start
now just a bonus tip and this is my
personal opinion
never get satanic tattoos or any other
evil tattoos
you might want to get it because you
might think that it will
let you look more tough to other people
but what you're actually doing is you're
just pushing people away from you
and you don't want to play around with
any satanic things because it is real
the devil
and these demons they are real i know
because i experienced it when i was
young but i also experienced how
powerful god is i experienced the
exorcisms when i was a kid my dad he was
a pastor so there was a lot of people
coming to him
to be freed from demons
if you want to check out my testimony on
it you can watch it here on my other
channel and i'll see you there
now remember
life is short so don't waste yours
cheers guys